ich gebe doch des staates preis wenn ich
ehrlich bin ist mein herze reichs
gefährden bisschen zeit schreibe noch
die letzte frage ob mit einer hellen
farbe als anders wär ich nehme an das
gute ich nehme an dass schlechte wahl
und das ganze nächte es ist eigentlich
der dem unzug ich auch keine schwäche
wenn du gehst dann noch selbst als
angriff ich will ich in 20 jahren vom
sternzeichen waage aufgewachsen in der
maximilian kolbe straße klar in der
schule war ich der einzige schwarze will
sich sieben war aber ist für meine
muttersprache ist
[Applaus]
alltäglich
ich bin deutsch ich sehe mich nicht
anders ich bin in meinen augen deutscher
und dass die kubanischen wurzeln das ist
dann eher so im blut die gute laune die
nicht habe dass ich immer positiv bin
das kommt von meinem vater
[Musik]
klar hast du hier immer ein paar leute
ja abends aus dem cosmo kommst raus und
gelungen sie dann alle im herum hast du
immer dabei klar und hat auch ein paar
wo die längst ok alleine würde ich jetzt
hier nicht unbedingt um laufen aber an
sich ist glaube ich glaube ich gar nicht
so krass anders wie in anderen städten
am anna zumindest ist mir da nichts
passiert weil hier auch viele menschen
sind muss man auch dazu sagen aber so
weit in die bahn einsteigt da kannst
dann doch schon mal dazu kommen dass
hier was passiert in der bahn weist er
nie aus welchen ecken die leute kommen
hierher kommst du verfügt wie folgt
[Musik]
ich hätte gern thüringer klöße einmal
mit von dollar jeder vierte rechnet
wahrscheinlich damit er hierher
geflüchtet bin nein ich bin hier geboren
ich kann genauso gut deutsch wie du
vielleicht sogar besser also also was
möchtest du mir erzählen und mit welchen
vorurteilen drückte mir gegenüber und
das hast du ihn herum leider gottes sehr
krass ich habe das glück dass ich mit
leuten umgeben mich umgebe die halt mein
mindset teilen ist die aktuelle
hochrechnung von 18 19 demnach kommt die
cdu auf 22 prozent die linke auf 29,8
die spd auf 8,1 die afc auf 23,2 hören
offenbar gemacht und wir in wenigen
jahren werden wir eine gesamte hospital
war auf diesem bild freunde gemeinsam
gehen werden
es hat schon irgendwie hier seinen klang
und das kann man nicht kleinreden
ich könnte jetzt sagen ja geht schon und
er führt es wunderschön und es gibt hier
wunderbare menschen aber um die geht es
mir nicht die brauche ich nicht mehr
erreichen es geht um die menschen die
von ihr mindset von ihren gedanken her
so abgedriftet sind weil sie angst haben
irgendwas zu verlieren oder so viel
schon verloren haben in ihrem leben das
sie einfach nichts mehr abgeben möchten
und den musste hingegen kommen und davon
haben wir halt einfach zu viele
waren airport beim einwohnermeldeamt vor
23 jahren wollte mich um melden weil ich
ausgezogen und war mit meiner mutter
dort weil ich das zum ersten mal gemacht
habe und da war ich da drin und die hat
mich behandelt als wäre ich nur ein
geparkter audi hat auch gesagt haben sie
doch ihre betreuerin wenn sie wenn sie
nichts verstehen und was meine mutter
und blond und weiß das heißt natürlich
dass meine beteuerung ist was erlauben
sie sich
[Musik]
gibt
seoul jetzt eine 50 im audimax wie lange
hast du familie
bei uns deutschen friseurin im nordosten
muss erst anrufen termin die ist das
anders bisher eine andere welt ist ein
bisschen cooler
zu uns deutschen gewesen sich auf das
ist ein schönes schön wie familie
[Applaus]
wir sind in camera art studios in erfurt
und sonst nehmen wir immer auf zu hause
auch bei mir oder bei ihm bei sound
direkt zu hause bei heutzutage hip hop
kannst du über auf dem brett kannst du
überall machen du brauchst nicht viel
kohle dafür wichtig ist der text ich
habe immer wenig zu tun ich gucke immer
nur zu beim aufbau
wenn er mir im gebiet macht und die
möglichkeit haben darüber zu sprechen
und fünf leute zu erreichen oder nur ein
der dann darüber nachdenkt der sich
gedanken darüber macht vielleicht selbst
irgendwas startet find ich super geil
finde ich super geil und das wichtig so
dafür ist ob da oder meine hübsche
hast du kopfhörer mit
text habe ich natürlich auf einem handy
fotografiert das immer ab also ich habe
auf dem laptop und dann fotografiere ich
das immer ab damit ich das dann
auswendig lernen kann so den part 1 auf
als es mal ohne text kommt können wir
sind heute betreut sondern bild
rinder mit power wo sind wir angekommen
wo sind wir hingegangen wir wollten frei
sein schau mal nach afghanistan
überrannt von den taliban und ich idiot
fahren auch immer keine straßenbahn
meine sorgen drücken kleinen dagegen nur
einen mausklick entfernt siehst du
menschen vom himmel regnen das ist kein
kinofilm das ist real du kannst sagen
was du willst wir haben immer eine wahl
sind die leute uns egal wir haben uns
gegen sie entschieden
da die letzten vier
sind die leute uns egal wir haben uns
gegen sie entschieden warten auf hilfe
doch stattdessen tun sich schießen wir
können sie retten zu lang hoffte sie auf
frieden doch in das flugzeug passen nur
7 diese dürfen aber nichts mehr glauben
nach den sternen sie müssen danach
brauchen sie sind die tränen meiner
liste deswegen sieht man sie nur draußen
sollen träumte oder aber nichts mehr
glauben begreifen nach den sternen sie
müssen dann abtauchen
ich find's schön mir gesetzt
auf den korrekten
ja
geht der punk ab egal menschen zuhört
und sie das sagt noch und gestmann
staaten die alle jederzeit kommen hart
aber herzlich
hallo
wo ich gerade meine
heimatstadt
[Musik]
lasst mich 14 gewesen seien 14 15 jahre
hatte was man da mit mädchen gehabt ja
auch nicht lange es war also eine kinder
beziehungen wie man so schön sagt und
genau hier werde ich es wenn ich nicht
vergessen ich hatte schulschluss bin
nach hause gegangen ich wohne hier in
der hat hier in der nähe gewohnt und
dann kam da das mädchen mit 34 nazis
also wirkliche nazis die mich als [ __ ]
beleidigt haben und haben mich hier
angesprochen blöd gemacht der mir
gefolgt bisher hinter und haben mich
geschlagen weggeschubst und ich bin dann
nach hause gerannt also auch so ein
erlebnis was mir mal wieder gezeigt hat
welche die schwarz wäre das nicht
passiert mit 14 15 da machst du dir über
sowas keine gedanken und rechnen ist ja
auch nicht damit dass wenn du jemanden
sagte ich möchte nicht mehr dass es dann
drei tage später irgendwelche nazis vor
oder in der schule stehen die eigene auf
die fresse hauen wollte
ich achte jetzt nicht drauf wie meine
umwelt aus schaut also ich drauf hatte
eine glatze oder nicht und wenn hat den
status und könnte er eventuell ein nazi
sein darüber mache ich mir gar keine
gedanken also ich gehe ich denke mehr an
mich selbst auch ins egoistisch klingt
aber ich bin mit mir selber sehr im
reinen und mich juckt es nicht ob jetzt
irgendjemand hier herum läuft und hat er
hätte was gegen mich so soll er haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist der fc union sportplatz
gegenüber von der alten radrennbahn
haben hier habe ich zehn jahre fußball
gespielt
habe viele wunderbare menschen
kennengelernt viele wunderbare momente
gehabt und viele siege gefeiert vor
allem
[Musik]
ich habe keinen zweifel dass die
zeiten sind vorbei
[Musik]
ich war mal hier auf dem platz da hat
man ein spiel gehabt ich weiß ich mehr
gegen wen das war und hat auch der
trainer von dem anderen team gesagt
haltet doch mal die maus nicht gemein ja
ich war der einzige
wie so oft war der einzige farbe auf dem
spielfeld da hat unser trainer dann auch
erstmal über der gemachten das gesagt
das geht nicht so und solche vorfälle
zeit einmal im jahr beim fußball sonst
beim fußball gar nicht
ich glaube das wird heute ganz besonders
dass wir da auch leute dabei haben die
hat wahrscheinlich gar nichts mit
deutsch rap anfangen können und
ich glaube das wird ganz geil dieses
klischee aufzubrechen und diese zwei
welten aufeinanderprallen zu lassen so
ein bisschen schöner tag wir haben heute
auftritte macht mal pipi
ich hoffe mal manchmal finde ist dass
die kreativ
kreativ garten entschuldigung
bis klein
mein kollege findet es nicht wir üben
das noch mit ankommen
ich hab den mann standort wir haben uns
beim workshop kennen gelernt und wir
haben uns so gut verstanden dass wir
irgendwann gesagt haben okay lass uns
zusammen mucke machen auf längere sicht
man 50 probiert sich aus auch gleich
bühnen so ich konnte immer was von ihm
lernen und dann habe ich das auch
gelernt 2 ich habe gerade über dich
gesprochen ich wusste gar nicht dass du
da bist
hintergrund angestrichen
ich bin ja eine 20 minuten gelände herum
gehört ich dachte ja ich kenne mich aus
ich habe gedacht ich komme ja als jungs
an dass die teams heißen kann
lageplan und so
[Musik]
hallo hallo erfurt hervor
wir sind so witty magma und dj sound ich
bin noch nicht eingehoben ich bin eben
ich rausgewachsen gegenwärtig möchte
sagt axel ware aus der nase und den
ohren heraus das
gefühl
ich habe immer an die wand gespielt auf
der stirn bei mir mal gesagt ich habe
mir gedacht ich stelle mich euch mal vor
ich heiße michael blanke perez bin 27
jahre alt halb kubaner mein dad kommt
aus kuba an meinem arm aus erfurt bin
hier geboren und groß geworden und ich
habe in dem song war so ein bisschen
widergespiegelt die meine 27 jahre in
erfurt abgelaufen sind man will sich gar
nicht fremd fühlen aber man sieht immer
wieder die blicke von den menschen und
fühlt sich irgendwie nicht willkommen
und das finde ich sehr schade deswegen
habe ich diesen song geschrieben und
wenn wir uns das nächste mal sehen
können wir uns begrüßen hallo sagen wir
kennen uns dann ein bisschen und dann
fühle ich mich gar nicht mehr so fremd
in dem land wo ich groß geworden bin wo
meine ganze familie groß geworden ist
das finde ich sehr schön dieses bild ist
es meiner heimatstadt sie schadet uns so
fabelhaft sie stehen schlange vor der
kasse das ist ja
das meiste weg gebracht wobei wieder war
klasse
ich nehme alles gute ich lebe einer
schlichten ich stehe bei aldi und das
ganze nächte er ist es schwer tun
zugleich auch eine schwäche wenn du
gehst dann nutze ist das special
[Musik]
bei den persönlichen texten gehe ich
dann immer voll rein weil ich auch genau
sie in berlin wie gucken die leute was
machst du jetzt nicht für mich nicht
verstecken so ist meine geschichte und
warum sollte ich mich davor schien so
die leute angefangen zu lächeln die
leute haben support wir haben kraft und
energie gehen es war schon geil so schön
zu sehen
[Musik]